are you one of the handful of people
still living in fear of catching the
wuflu well Pfizer is here to help not
just with its Infamous vaccines but with
a drug to treat the virus available to
you right now as long as you're willing
to accept the possibility of a few side
effects
my symptoms are mild now but I'm not
waiting if it's covered pack slavid
having even one risk factor like being
over 50 diabetes or smoking increases
your chances of severe covet taken
within five days of symptoms Pax lovid
reduced the risk of developing severe
covid-19 by 86 percent taxlobin May
strengthen or weaken other medicines
taking it with certain medicines may
cause life-threatening side effects or
affect how Pax lovid works so it's
critical to tell your doctor about all
medicines you take including herbal
supplements because lab tests or
changing the dose of your medicines may
be needed tell your doctor if you have
any serious illnesses allergies liver or
kidney disease are pregnant or plan to
become pregnant are breastfeeding or use
birth control Pax lobid may affect how
your birth control works don't take Pax
lovit if you're allergic to nurmitral
beer retana beer or any of its
ingredients serious side effects can
include allergic reactions liver
problems and issues with HIV medicines
other side effects include altered taste
diarrhea high blood pressure muscle
aches abdominal pain nausea and feeling
unwell
is that all
the drug might cause other drugs you're
taking to stop working it might break
your liver your kidneys your gestating
baby or your nursing baby it might cause
nausea high blood pressure or bowel
problems and it might kill you
but if you're willing to accept all of
those risks the drug might reduce the
severity of what for most people feels
like a common cold
if it's covered
Pax Lovin
you might wind up deceased but Pfizer's
prophets will be increased your kidneys
might turn off
but it might improve your cough I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from soup who says
it's amazing how many people want to
grill Michael for calling Jeffree Star a
transvestite he is while they don't even
know what that means that's true a lot
of people came after me yesterday
because I referred to that guy Jeffree
Star as a transvestite that the
conservatives were all lauding because
he he's fine with transgenderism but he
says that non-binary pronouns that's too
far and I said he's a transvestite and
if this is the new line then
conservatives are totally sunk we
haven't conserved anything
he is a transvestite he might not
identify as transgender or whatever but
I don't really use the word transgender
all that much when I'm referring to a
person because there's no such thing as
transgenderism because a man can't
really be a woman or a woman can't
become a man you know that I care a lot
about words and I try to use precise
language when I can there's a great book
about that called speechless controlling
words controlling Minds which is
available now you can order it there we
go transvestite just means you put on
the clothing of the opposite sex and so
that's what he is and facts don't care
about your feelings don't know what to
tell you about that okay when you want
to preserve any kind of stability in our
very unstable culture when you want some
material stability I would highly
recommend you check out Birch gold right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the U.S
blew through 31.4 trillion dollars in
debt ceiling last month and still the
White House refuses to reduce spending
with the U.S economy facing
unprecedented challenges it is more
important than ever to diversify your
portfolio with a trusted and secure
investment like gold you need gold with
Birch gold when you invest in gold you
are investing in a tangible asset that
has stood the test of time I have really
really enjoyed investing in Precious
Metals in my life I'm very very pleased
to own gold from Birch gold unlike
stocks or bonds gold has intrinsic value
it is not tied to any one country's
economic performance that means that no
matter what happens to the US economy
your investment in Gold will remain
secure and valuable text Knowles kwles
to 98 9898 to claim your free info kit
on gold and then talk to one of their
precious metals Specialists with an A
plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text Knowles kwles to 98 98.98
and protect yourself with gold today
that is Knolls to 98 98 98 today
the side effects list in that covid
medicine commercial
it's like two-thirds of the commercial
now listen my symptoms aren't that bad
yet because it's coveted and it just
doesn't get that bad for pretty much
everybody
but if it did get bad I would take this
drug that could kill me
so that I have fewer aches for a few
days
speaking of medical malpractice
a really big Story coming out of Canada
this is speaking of transgenderism too
this is a story that we have been
calling for and predicting for years now
really since the transgender craze
started and we're finally seeing it
happen a d transitioner is suing her
medical providers a woman in Ontario who
identified as transgender and underwent
hormone therapy a bilateral mastectomy
and a hysterectomy this woman had her
womb removed filed the first lawsuit in
Canada against her doctors for
facilitating her transition which is a
euphemism for chopping up healthy people
who are suffering from
chopping up their healthy body parts
in order to indulge their their
disordered and destructive fantasies
that's what the doctors did it's not
This Woman's fault people fall prey to
all the times but doctors take the
Hippocratic oath and doctors swear a vow
first to do no harm and what the
transgender affirming doctors are doing
is a lot of harm and this woman is
recognizing this because she's snapped
out of her and she said wait a second
I'm not really a man and what have you
people done to me you've chopped off my
body parts and you've removed my womb so
now I can never have a child
the one his name is Michelle zakina
she is 34 years old
she
pointed out that these medical
professionals failed to address her
complex mental health needs I'm going to
put a pause here for a second because I
would not be surprised if what I just
said in the you version of this show
gets cut out because YouTube has all
sorts of rules about how you're supposed
to talk about transgenderism and you're
not supposed to refer to it as a
even though that's obviously what it is
and so what what happens is for the
YouTube part of the show sometimes the
better they'll put a sensor bar or
they'll say you've got to go to
dailywire.com visit dailywire.com we can
say whatever we want we're not going to
be de-platformed by you we're not going
to receive any further strikes on our
account on YouTube or the other
platforms but that's obviously what it
is you don't need to take my word for it
that's what this woman is saying the
woman who identified as transgender for
a long time and had her breasts cut off
and had her womb removed she is now
saying I had a
and my doctors failed to treat my
and now
now I've had much of my life destroyed
because of it she says I will live the
rest of my life without breasts
and deepened voice with male pattern
balding and without the ability to get
pregnant removing my completely healthy
uterus is my greatest regret
and so she's saying it's a regret that I
have she's taking some responsibility
for for falling into this but she
shouldn't take all of the responsibility
or even most of it none of these
transgender people are they've fallen
into maybe that's through the Indulgence
of Vice a lot of people get into it
because they're addicted to porn maybe
that's because of certain
that they have a major uh Associated
factor for transgender identity is
awesome that sometimes goes undiagnosed
or maybe it's because of any other
number of host of that are associated
with transgenderism the people that I
blame are not the people who fall into
it the people that I blame are the ones
who indulge it and especially the
doctors who took an oath to do no harm
and they're chopping out this woman's
uterus and they're severely damaging the
rest of her life I hope she sues them
for all that they're worth I hope these
these medical facilities go totally
bankrupt if they're not first banned by
the state
I hope these doctors lose their licenses
and I hope this is totally banned for
everybody as soon as possible throughout
the West this is a horrifying thing this
woman is just the first really public
victim to come forward in Canada and Sue
I I want to see thousands and thousands
of these lawsuits I strongly encourage
anybody who regrets being transitioned
to sue these people for all that they're
worth especially people who are
transitioned at a young age which is
happening more and more and more
teenagers some sometimes even younger
which brings us to and almost entirely
different
political issue right now so the war in
Ukraine which is really a proxy war
between Russia which invaded Ukraine and
America which has tried to deepen ties
to Ukraine and has encouraged Ukraine to
apply for membership in the European
Union and turn toward NATO for
protection and has has tried to oust
some of the more pro-russian leaders of
that country now you've got a proxy war
in what was once a buffer state
well Vladimir Putin has just raised the
stakes of the war because he's choosing
not to
continue along with a major nuclear
treaty this is the new start treaty he's
saying that he's going to suspend the
new start treaty doesn't really Bode
very well for the war and in a speech in
which he lambasted the West he attacked
the West specifically for the woke virus
that it is spreading around the world
that that Vladimir Putin says is
threatening
the children of non-western States
Russian children and and other places
where the culture hasn't totally seeped
in I'll I'll translate the speech not
not from Russian but I'll read the
subtitles while he speaks
and theater they lie constantly perverts
historical facts do not stop attacks on
our culture
and other traditional religious
organizations of our country see what
they do with their own peoples this is
in the west the destruction of the
family cultural the national identity
of children and pedophilia or declared
the norm of their life and Priests are
forced to bless same-sex marriages
god with them let them do what they want
what do I want to say here I don't have
the right to live as they want we have
always thought like this in Russia and
we always will first of all right
no one will invade private lives we are
not going to do this I know we were
Communists for like a hundred years but
forget about that
but I want to tell them look at the holy
scriptures the main books of all other
world religions everything is said there
including that the family is the union
of a man in the world
Russian legislators out there what these
sacred texts
it became known the Anglican Church for
example plans to consider the idea of a
gender neutral God the Russian accent is
getting worse the longer this goes along
what can we say
forgive us Lord they know not what they
do
millions of people
understand that they are leading to a
real spiritual disaster the elites
directly I must say go crazy and it
seems that they can no longer be treated
show me the LIE there but these are
their problems as I said and we must
protect our children and we will do this
protect our children from degradation
and degeneration I talked on the show
yesterday about
the the most important aspect of good
propaganda
and coincidentally now we're seeing
Vladimir Putin who's an excellent
propagandist exercise this good
propaganda
is the kind that's true
and even if it's not a hundred percent
true it's got a lot of truth to it there
are a lot of things that Vladimir Putin
is suggesting here that are not true
he's suggesting that in the west the
church blames or blesses rather same-sex
marriage that isn't true that is true in
some of the Protestant churches though
it's not true in the Catholic Church
which is the Church of the West for 2000
years but it's true in some Protestant
churches there's a there's a fair bit of
Truth to that
it's true that in the west now the West
doesn't really respect many aspects of
private life now of course Russia was
the Communist Empire for much of the
20th century so I don't want to hear Too
Many lectures about respecting private
life from Vladimir Putin okay but he's
right about what he's saying about the
West in many ways he's saying that in
the west there are policies encouraging
the destruction of the family that's
true Russia has not been very successful
at promoting The Rebirth of the family
but they have taken certain State
measures to turn around their birth rate
problem and encourage the family
it's true no Russia has a lot of other
problems than that they allow all sorts
of pornography and they promote I think
they even promote sort of underage
pornography and all sorts of abusive
terrible stuff but what they're saying
about the West
there's a lot of truth to it the
degeneration the degradation that's
being pushed in the west that's a
problem he's saying we're going to
protect our kids from that that's the
kind of message that is going to
resonate that's very very good
propaganda and you can say well Vladimir
Putin you're misrepresenting your
country well Vladimir Putin you're Mis
representing your War aims well Vladimir
Putin you're you're a meanie and you're
a terrible guy you can say all that that
can all be true
but much if not most of what he is
accusing the west of doing is true what
are we going to do about it if we want
Vladimir Putin to have less effective
propaganda we should probably
we should probably stop encouraging the
conditions that allow a lot of that
propaganda
to be true okay that's that's just real
talk folks and when you want real talk
you should check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com use promo code nulls
I got to ask you something if you had
two cups of coffee that came from the
same pot but one of them cost two
dollars and the other cost one dollar
which cup would you buy
of course you would buy the more
affordable coffee it's the same coffee
for less money what if I told you you
could get the same wireless service for
Less
stop paying for Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
cut your bill in half with pure talk
Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies they're the only
Wireless company that offers a 100 money
back guarantee they are so sure that
you're going to love their service that
if you don't they will give you your
money back they're us-based customer
service team makes the switch super easy
switch over to Pure Talk in as little as
10 minutes while keeping your phone and
your phone number your first month is
guaranteed risk free go to puretalk.com
enter promo code Knolls Canada wlas to
save 50 off your first month that is
puretalk.com promo code Knowles kwles
Pure Talk is simply smarter Wireless
speaking of the war in Ukraine
a major
incident in the presidential race in
2024 that a lot of people aren't talking
about it's not that there's a new
candidate though there is a new
candidate we'll get to that in a second
probably the the biggest change in the
2024 race is that we have now I think
for the first time gotten a foreign
policy statement from the chief
Republican rival to Donald Trump Ron
DeSantis here's what Ron DeSantis thinks
about the war in Ukraine
they have effectively a blank check
policy with no clear strategic objective
identified and these things can can
escalate and I don't think it's in our
interest to be getting into proxy war
with China getting involved over things
like the Borderlands or over Crimea so I
think it would behoove them to identify
what is the Strategic objective that
they're trying to to achieve but just
saying it's an open-ended blank check
that is not acceptable so Governor what
does a win look like for us in Ukraine
for Ukraine
well I think it's important to point out
I mean you know the fear of kind of
Russia going into NATO countries and all
that and steamrolling you know that has
not even come close to happening I think
they've shown themselves to be a
third-rate military power I think
they've suffered tremendous tremendous
losses I got to think that the people in
Russia are probably disapproving of
what's going on I don't think they can
speak up about it for obvious reasons so
I think Russia has been really really
wounded here and I don't think that they
are the same threat to our country even
though they're hostile I don't think
they're on the same level as a China
this is a masterful answer from Ron
DeSantis because don't forget Donald
Trump's greatest strength in the
president presidential race today is
probably his foreign policy
it was the most different from the other
Republican rivals in 2016 and from
probably most other Republican
politicians today
and it's the most effective foreign
policy we've seen certainly in my
lifetime
it's the most effective foreign policy
certainly since George H.W bush maybe
since Ronald Reagan
because Donald Trump was unpredictable
the bad guys were not nearly as
aggressive on Donald Trump's watch as
they have been on the watch of other
presidents Donald Trump scored major
foreign policy wins Donald Trump brought
a fair degree of peace to the Middle
East which people probably would not
have guessed when when he was first
elected but he has a very strong foreign
policy record
and the GOP base is torn right now
between the
the really bullish pro-war go in glass
Russia take over Ukraine's side which is
not as represented among the base but
the GOP Elites really like that idea and
then the base and the more paleo
conservative and the more isolationist
side which says why are we focused on
Kiev when we've got a chemical spill in
East Palestine Ohio people can't drink
the water in their town but we're
focused on giving pensions to ukrainians
for what give me a break
and then you've got the more hawkish
side in the GOP saying no if we don't go
in and take over Ukraine uh Vladimir
Adolf Putin is going to conquer all of
Europe he's not only the next Hitler
he's the next Napoleon he's the next
he's the next Genghis Khan we have to
stop him now and and how does Ron
DeSantis handle this
he says
the threat from Russia has been
exaggerated there is not evidence that
Russia is going to steamroll into Poland
or Hungary or other places in the West
and
Russia's been degraded Russia has been
revealed to be not a very strong nuclear
not a very strong military power they
are a nuclear power so there is still
some threat there it's a very good
answer it's a very good answer for
Rhonda Santos we'll see
how that keeps up talk is cheap of
course and Trump has the advantage of
having had an actual foreign policy it's
not desantis's fault Florida just
doesn't have a foreign policy we will
see now how consistent Rhonda Santos can
be in his foreign policy as as for Trump
Trump because he's already pretty
squared away on the foreign policy stuff
he can focus on matters at home and that
is where Donald Trump really really
shines so Joe Biden flies over to Kiev
to Pal around with zielinski the
president of Ukraine
Donald Trump says I'm going to East
Palestine Ohio in fact Trump has made
such a fuss about this I believe he's
going to East Palestine today so we'll
see more from the rally later on he's
made such a fuss about this that I think
at least be Buddha judge and probably
Joe Biden are going to have to make a
visit as well
so Trump's most distinguishing
characteristic from the high level
perspective of the candidates is
probably the foreign policy that's why
you're seeing the GOP candidates trying
to figure out exactly how to thread that
needle but where Trump shines the most
is when he goes to the Rust Belt when he
goes to Blue Collar places when he goes
to the Forgotten man the flyover country
the bitter clinging
Bible thumping
deplorable irredeemable people that the
Democrats and the elite Republicans hate
when he goes there and he speaks to
their concerns
and he he breaks away from the free
trade Orthodoxy globalization Orthodoxy
Outsource everything and flood the
country with foreigners Orthodoxy that
took over not just the leftist
institutions but even the right wing
think tanks and Elite institutions on
the coasts when Trump contradicts that
that is where he shines that is a big
break from the rest of the GOP which has
now been remade in Trump's image
he he I suspect is going to do very very
well in Ohio now the other thing that
distinguished Trump is that Trump was
not a career politician he's a
businessman there is another businessman
candidate in the race just announced his
run for President yesterday that would
be my friend the fake ramaswami
achievement was my ticket to get ahead I
went on to found multi-billion dollar
companies and I did it while getting
married raising a family and following
my faith in God the things that used to
fill that void like faith
patriotism hard work and family have
disappeared
we now embrace one secular religion
after another
from covetism
climatism and gender ideology to satisfy
our deeper need for identity yet we
cannot even answer the question of what
it means to be an American in the year
2023. this isn't just a political
campaign
this is a cultural movement to create a
new dream for the next generation of
Americans and this time around
it isn't just about money
it's about the Unapologetic pursuit of
excellence in our country
this is a great message
this is a really really great message
the vague opens up the announcement with
talk about Martin Luther King and I have
a dream and the sort of stuff that
people have heard before so you might
start to think all right this is going
to be a regular old Republican talking
points campaign but notice how quickly
he shifts it
and he says I'm running a campaign about
American identity
and
who we are he's focusing on
culture he's focusing on religion he
says we've got to do away with the
climate religion I really like that
phrase that's what it is it's a the
climatism the the green people they not
the little green men from outer space
that everyone said was flying over
Montana the other day but the the green
movement that worships mother Gaia that
is a false religion we got to get away
from that
what are we going to go back to he says
there I've got faith in God okay that's
going to be a traditional religion
what's our identity
he says our identity is not going to be
just about money this time that's an
amazing amazing statement because the
Republican talking points for 30 years
have been hey do whatever you want
believe whatever you want behave however
you want just don't make me pay for it
the fake saying nope none of that what
are we going to pursue instead he says
we're going to pursue excellence
that is a very very traditional
conservative idea
excellence
maybe maybe in the ancient Greek orete
this idea that we want to pursue not
just maximal individual autonomy but
excellence in all of our fields
that we perhaps want to pursue virtue
that we want good stuff more good stuff
less bad stuff that's a very compelling
campaign message and I know some people
are saying oh this guy Vivek who is he
is he just the Andrew Yang of this cycle
does he really know what he's talking
about with politics I told you when
there were first Rumblings that Vivek
might run for president I said this is a
very serious guy I know him I've known
him for quite a long time and
this guy's very intelligent this guy has
a Clear Vision he's not just some Joker
vanity candidate running
he he is going to run with a purpose
and as he said there he said it's bigger
than one candidate most most of the time
when politicians say that I think it's
just BS it's actually all they really
care about is their their own
aggrandizement and and Power
the vague is offering something here
we'll see how the campaign goes this is
the this is the first day of the
campaign basically
very impressive launch especially for a
candidate who comes really out of left
field not leftist field what comes out
of left field comes out of the blue
people were not expecting this guy to
run an auspicious start to his campaign
now speaking of auspicious moments I'm
very excited I'm hopeful I'm I'm looking
forward to the future because
I will get to hear from you on Friday in
the voicemail back the way to submit a
question in the voicemail back is you go
to thedailywire.com you click on my show
page you
go down to the mailbag and you click the
button submit a mail by question it's
going to pop up with an email screen
what you do then is you just attach your
audio file you can record your audio
file on your computer you can record
your audio file on your phone you can
record it on a cassette player I don't
really care somehow get this digital
file to be less than one minute attach
it to the email send it in and then I
will get to hear your mellifluous voice
on the show on Friday
so you got a bunch of Republicans
running for president
they're all running at least ostensibly
against Joe Biden and Joe Biden is not
looking great
you saw the contrast the Republicans are
focused on Ohio Joe Biden's focused on
Kiev Joe Biden flew to Kiev just the
other day took a lot of big photo ops
with Vladimir zielinski and even as Joe
Biden was walking out you heard an air
raid siren going on here's our Intrepid
president walking out in a war zone it's
pretty crazy because Joe Biden doesn't
seem totally stable or safe when he's
walking out on the lawn of the White
House but now he's flying into this war
zone with air raid sirens wow this is
pretty cool man look at Clint Eastwood
over here except
one could not help but have the
impression that the whole scene was
staged and it's not just me saying that
it's not just the conservative it's not
not just the conspiracy theorist tinfoil
hat wearing people even CNN admitted the
whole scene looked a little bit sus
I've been here for the past five days I
have not heard any explosions I have not
heard any air Sirens until about half an
hour ago right when uh President Biden
was in the center of Kiev
so CNN doesn't make the accusation that
CNN's Alex marquart he says look I'm not
I'm not making any accusations but I've
been here for five days I haven't once
heard an air raid siren
and the only air raid siren I've heard
just coincidentally happens when Biden
walks out the door with Vladimir
zielinski
as I mentioned the other day you know
I'm not a conspiracy theorist
I am simply a coincidence noticer
and that is pretty pathetic it reminds
me of Hillary Clinton saying that when
she landed in Bosnia she landed under
sniper fire she was in a war zone it was
just total BS it's the same thing for
Joe Biden as well
it's a deception and not not a very
persuasive one
speaking of deception
you were regularly scheduled update
on
white women pretending to be ethnic this
from the New York Post
a progressive activist
Raquel Evita Saraswati
she is a Muslim Progressive activist
she is an Arab woman she is a Latina she
has made this ethnic
uh identity part of her activism for 20
years and it turns out you're going to
be shocked to hear this she's just a
regular white lady
39 years old
was just outed by The Intercept for
pretending to be
South Asian Latina
and Arab
uh she she spoke to boston.com in 2004
about her upcoming wedding saying she
she wanted to do something to respect
her Arab and Latin culture actually her
name is Rachel Elizabeth Seidel
she uh she's referred to in that article
as Raquel Evita Seidel I guess she has
dropped the Seidel now she's Sarah
sawati and her mother Carol Peroni
says that it's all Bs and her family is
white as the driven snow
I call her Rachel I don't know why she's
doing what she's doing I'm as white as
the driven snow and so is she I'm German
and British her father was Calabrese
Italian which to be fair is a racially
liminal group of people I happen to be
Calabrese as well she's chosen to live a
lie and I find that very very sad what
is Sarah swati's job
do you think she's a truck driver no do
you think she's an electrician no she is
of course
the chief Equity inclusion and culture
officer
of a philadelphia-based group The
American friends service committee which
is a leftist Quaker group that fights
violence inequality and
oppression
she's the latest Rachel dollazole but
there have been many Rachel dollazals
since then lots of white women usually
women
pretend to be
other ethnic groups why is that
because
exhibit Z exhibit number 10 576.
that white privilege
does not exist
it does not exist certainly as our
culture pretends that it exists you
don't get special social points for
being white in fact white people are the
only group in our culture that one can
legally discriminate against and a
socially insult exclude ostracize where
it's actually encouraged by our culture
to attack white people and so
white people are pretending to be other
races
it's just basic incentives the proof of
the pudding is in the tasting
you don't see many if any black people
pretending to be white people you don't
see many Arab people or middle eastern
people pretending to be white people in
fact
in the U.S census Arab and Middle
Eastern people used to be classified as
white then there was a movement over the
last 10 years to reclassify that group
as Middle Eastern and North African Mena
Linda sarsour the leftist activist was
one of the people pushing this why was
she pushing this if there were a
privilege associated with being white
don't you think that the people who were
already lumped in as being white would
want to remain White
they're not doing that though why
because being white is the only group
with which there is not a social
privilege Associated so they're trying
to be some other group and yet if you
went out and you pulled a hundred people
on the street
in New York San Francisco Chicago
Washington DC if you pulled any CNN
Watchers so I guess you'd have to go to
the airport for that and you said hey
which group is the most socially
privileged
you would hear a lot of people say oh
it's white people
it's white people it's the opposite of
reality so often we can just be
hypnotized
by by the popular culture but this is
the proof that it's all Bs speaking of
privilege
speaking of white white privilege
a gang member in La is a Korean guy
this Korean guy comes with his family to
America as a kid
he then joined a gang and committed
murder
and then he went to a prison for that
and now he's being deported because he
got out of prison which is absurd the
guy committed murder he should at the
very least be in prison for the rest of
his life
but okay fine let's say
[Music]
for let's let's say we're a legitimate
reason for which he was granted some
clemency here some mercy he was allowed
out of prison he is being deported he's
not an American citizen he is a Gangster
and a murderer and so he's being
deported this is being reported in the
New York Times or I'm sorry the LA Times
as a kind of a sad story
this guy Justin Chung
Justin Tung Chung was brutally honest
admitting that it took him years to feel
remorse he wanted to share his
complicated journey and he was rallying
support for another fight
because of the murder he committed when
he was 16 he had lost his chance to
apply for a green card he's on the verge
of being deported to South Korea the
country he left is a two-year-old
especially being Korean I do want to be
private for my family said Chung 33 but
I have to fight
I have to do something before I get
deported
no you don't just go go away go away
you're very very lucky that you were
allowed out of prison
because of the Democrat policies of
people like Gavin Newsom you're very
very lucky that you were not executed
when you committed that Murder In Cold
Blood when he committed that murder
he was in a gang he thought he was
killing people of a rival gang he just
didn't like the cut of their jib or the
kind of clothes they were wearing so he
went to murder them and it turned out
the people that he murdered were not in
any gang at all
they were just in the wrong place at the
wrong time in this cold-blooded psycho
murdered them
so now he's getting deported and now
that's the sob story
that's the sob story that is how
much our culture favors
immigrants
the the foreigners the people who they
look different they sound a little
different that's how insanely our
culture favors them is that they can
come here literally commit murder
and they're still the sympathetic
characters in the story
You Remember When Donald Trump in 2016
he said my followers love me so much I
could shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue and
I wouldn't lose a single vote and the
left used this line they said oh my
goodness this is cultish behavior this
is horrible can you imagine what a
terrible country we're living in where
that sort of statement can be true well
it's not exactly true of trump his
followers are pretty loyal but he was
exaggerating for Comic effect
that is true when it comes to the libs
and immigration they could literally
murder people they do regularly murder
people
and the libs will not lift a finger to
do anything about it
in fact they will lift a finger to try
to stop these poor put upon murderers
from being deported
speaking of murderers in prison
great story coming out of Miami
reported in the Miami Herald
headline held without charge a Miami
inmate's unborn child asks court for
release in odd case
what's the story well an attorney
William n Norris filed an emergency writ
of habeas corpus which allows the court
to determine whether someone's
imprisonment is lawful they say this
lawyer is speaking not on behalf of his
client who's committed murder but of an
unborn child
I'm sorry allegedly committed murder
but rather it's on behalf of an unborn
child
who he says has not been charged with
any crime by the state further the state
has placed the unborn child and such
inherently dangerous environment by
placing The Unborn Child in close
proximity to Violent criminal Defenders
the child's mother or 24 years old was
arrested and charged with second-degree
murder while she was six weeks pregnant
so now there's two people being held in
this jail
and the lawyer was saying well
on behalf of one of my clients that that
person's being held without a charge and
that would be the unborn baby
I love this case
this is a real post Dobbs case
this is a case that shows
it's probably going to be laughed at of
court but it shows
a major shift now that Roe v Wade has
been overruled now that Planned
Parenthood be case he's been overruled
people are beginning
to talk about babies in the womb as
actual babies
and they're not just doing it from
places of sincerity or because their
minds have been changed they're doing it
from places of opportunism looking at
how the law is now treating unborn
babies which is fine by me I don't
either way I don't I just want the
babies to be treated as babies now of
course this is absurd and the reason
it's absurd though is not that the baby
is not really a baby the reason it's
absurd is that the baby is not primarily
an individual the reason this legal
motion is absurd is because none of us
are primarily individuals man is a
political animal man is a social animal
that was the wisdom of Aristotle that
was the wisdom that animated the
political philosophy of the West and
only in recent Years Around The
Enlightenment into modernity did some of
the liberal thinkers start to say no no
man's not a social political animal
man's an individual and we're all just
atomized individuals floating in The
Ether and we've all gotten much more
miserable since that time
the baby cannot be separated from the
mother
man is a social animal if the mother
murders somebody and goes to prison the
baby is going to have to go to prison
too at least for nine months
that's that's another political truth
that we're going to have to learn or
relearn we're going to have to relearn
that man is not simply an individual
floating outer space we're not born
primarily with rights and entitlements
as individuals we are actually born with
duties and responsibilities to our
family we're born into that social
context into the context of a Township
into the context of a state into the
concept of a Nation
and into that whole political Community
we do have something to do with one
another that's the lesson that we're
gonna have to start learning now but I
love that we've learned that first
lesson and we're learning it pretty well
babies are in fact people absolutely
love it in honor of President's Day this
year the daily wire launched our
president's for sale sale with 40 off
memberships the big guy got 10 we're
giving you 40 get access to the world of
daily wire plus with Fearless
documentaries gripping movies Dennis
prager's master's program and the entire
library of Dr Jordan Peterson's work
including new productions Exodus logos
and literacy on marriage all available
to watch right now coming soon
new episodes of Ben Shapiro's the search
Jordan Peterson's vision and Destiny and
exodus part 2 are much anticipated DW
kids content and the Epic Pendragon Saga
later this year we are also giving you
up to 40 off select items in the daily
wire shop take advantage of our
presidents for sale sale today go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today that is dailywire.com
subscribe
speaking of young people it's a story
from last week but I do want to get to
it the doj has announced that it won't
charge Matt Gates Republican Congressman
with any crimes you might recall that
there was a big Scandal people thought
Not only was Matt Gates going to get run
out of Washington DC but he was going to
wind up in an orange jumpsuit because
they accused him of sex trafficking not
just any sex trafficking underage sex
trafficking and they accused him of this
because apparently Matt Gates is a
single guy and likes to hang out with
women and I guess one of these women may
or may not have been underage at the
time and maybe it was in a different
state and anyway there were all these
allegations they were trying to portray
Matt Gates as a
pedophile they were trying to portray
Matt Gates as Jeffrey Epstein you know
the guy that the Democrat Elites all
hung out with for years and years and
years with total impunity they're
they're trying to portray Matt gates in
that way and ultimately it appears not
to have worked all that well from the
legal perspective because the doj
is confirmed to Matt Gates's attorneys
that their investigation has concluded
and he will not be charged with any
crimes
okay does this exonerate Matt Gates
should he settle down and get married
and stop hanging out with lots of girls
uh yeah he probably should do that it
doesn't exonerate him on the personal
level I guess but it certainly
exonerates him on the legal level and
that's very very important
one it's important for the separation of
powers if the doj of some executive
agency can go around
arresting members of Congress
willy-nilly that that becomes a Norm
that's that's a big problem for the
separation of powers in our country
then it's just the executive agencies
and the bureaucracy runs the whole
government
and the legislature the duly elected
representatives and the judges and
everybody else is just subservient to
them not the way the Constitution's
supposed to work
so it's good it's good that Matt Gates
is not being charged but it's not a
total win for Gates it's not a total win
for republicans
because the libs basically got what they
want
Matt Gates was tried in the court of
public opinion
Matt Gates had all of these insinuations
leveled against him
the very fact of being under
investigation for this kind of stuff
with all kinds of leaks and all sorts of
naughty implications coming out of it
really damaged This Guy's political
career
he's never going to get that stain off
of him
does he bear some responsibility for
that I suppose so but this was also a
political operation this was also an
attack by the libs they didn't need to
get him
they didn't need to put them in that
orange jumpsuit
in order in order to get him in order to
severely damage him this is what they
did to Trump for years
with Trump they said for you oh he's
maybe colluding with the Russians we're
gonna have to investigate that oh he
maybe cheated in 2016 we're gonna have
to investigate that we're in a special
counsel oh he maybe has this crooked
deal oh we've got to investigate
investigate investigate
and then what did they have they had
nothing at all we got to kick in his
door at Mar-A-Lago he's got secret
documents apparently nowhere near the
number of secret documents in nowhere
near the number of places that Joe Biden
had next to his Corvette in his Chinese
funded fake think tank at Penn and all
these other places no Trump he maybe he
was selling the nuclear codes we don't
know and so they don't ever charge him
with anything because they don't have
anything on him but the the very fact
that they can make these insinuations is
damaging enough that is a political
operation and they could do it to
anybody
they could do it
to anybody who crosses them think about
the data that they have on you all of
the surveillance every naughty thing
you've ever looked up online every
impolitic email or text message you've
ever sent
that's in in a surveillance State such
as we have that means it's all available
they're not going to go after you now
they've probably unless you're a
criminal they probably don't have things
where you've actually violated the law
but they can embarrass you they can harm
you they can that's a lot of power being
wielded by a bureaucracy that is mostly
unaccountable
speaking of cultural power
this is a story that was trending
yesterday on Twitter I didn't know how
much interest it would be to the public
at large but it's a great deal of
interest to me and it actually does have
some pretty deep political implications
it's a story relating to the Catholic
Church there's a big fight in the
Catholic church over the Latin Mass some
Catholics myself included like to go to
the old Mass which is in Latin but there
are a lot of different things about it
compared to the new Mass
yes it's in Latin but the priest is
facing the altar there are many more
prayers it tends to be much more
reverent and respectful and traditional
and the symbolism tends to be much
richer and so
a lot of Catholics especially young
Conservative Catholics especially the
ones who
believe the teachings of the church
especially the ones that are having lots
of kids especially the ones that are
returning to the faith
they tend to prefer that Latin mass and
the the new mass that came about 50
years ago roughly is being promoted by a
lot of liberal Boomers in the church
that's kind of the main constituency and
you go to those churches those parishes
where they've got the new mass in
English with not just in English but the
priest is facing the people and he's
yucking it up during the homily and
there's a mariachi band in the corner
and they've got clowns dancing up and
down the aisle I'm only half
exaggerating with that one and it's all
really sappy and it it it it it it it
basically looks like a rock opera from
the 1970s that wasn't cool even then
unfortunately a lot of the time that's
what the liturgical abuse looks like so
young people are are drawn more toward
Orthodoxy tradition reverence smells and
bells lifting your eyes up to heaven not
a liturgy that is more worldly not
liturgy that is more casual not a
liturgy that is
less respectful
the pope is clamping down on this and he
just issued an edict yesterday that
would essentially ban the Latin mass for
all intents and purposes in most
Diocesan churches around the country and
one of the big promoters of this a
liberal Catholic writer
Massimo fagioli tweeted out he said the
Absurd situation is that while the USA
and Russia are moving toward the brink
of nuclear war the Vatican has to deal
with liturgical Wars within the Catholic
Church
I thought hold on has to what do you
mean has to they don't have to do this
the Vatican and certain liberals in the
Vatican are picking this fight to attack
the relatively small number of people
who attend the the traditional Mass
though there's a lot of growth there and
it's young people and they're very
energetic and they're very very vibrant
compared to some of the more ossifying
elements of the the church
it says no they have to do this they
have to I don't think they have to do
this they're choosing to do this but
they're choosing to do this for good
reason and this is where we can all
learn a political lesson whether you're
Catholic or not whether you go to church
or not the political lesson is
that liturgy really matters liturgy by
by which I mean the way that we enact
our worship
the getting down on our knees and the
smells and the bells and the pla the way
that we pray and what we pray to and the
the modes of our Behavior
really really matter there's a Latin
expression Lex or rondi Lex credenti Lex
vivendi the way that we worship
will affect the way that we believe
it's not just that the way we believe
affects the way that we worship and
behave it's the way that we act will
actually affect our opinions and and
that will in turn affect
the whole way that we live our lives
and when when a kid in a school stands
up before
school and says the Pledge of Allegiance
that is going to inculcate a Spirit of
patriotism in him a love of his country
I guess it's explicit you're pledging
allegiance to your country
but more it's implicit the fact that
you're standing up for the flag the fact
that you're putting your hand over your
heart
the fact that you are imbuing this
symbol of the flag with meaning what's
the symbol represent the country you're
going to love that country if you if you
don't love your country and you want to
teach a whole generation not to love the
country
yeah you can teach them other history
books yeah you can lambast them with all
sorts of diatribes against America and
George Washington all the rest they do
that too
but probably the most effective way
you're going to do it is just don't have
them say the Pledge of Allegiance
anymore
just take that flag out of the classroom
or for it's in the classroom disrespect
it
just have them not take any of these
things seriously
because we're corporeal beings we're
incarnate so our we live in time and
space the things that we do with our
body the things that we do with our time
that's going to affect the way that we
believe if you devote a lot of your time
to
God to prayer you're you're going to be
more religious
you are going to believe more deeply
that's going to affect your life much
more if instead you say look I believe
in God I believe in religion but I spend
all my time just playing video games or
eating potato chips or going to the
movies you're going to be less religious
you're going to be more focused on that
that's what culture is culture and cult
come from the same root word what the
culture
worships is going to Define that culture
and what does the Culture worship well
you know the tree by its fruit you know
you know the pudding from the tasting
how many more metaphors can I use
what are we doing
the very smart stuff from the Liberals
in the Vatican
if they want people to disregard some of
those old teachings that have only
persisted for 2000 years in the church
they want people
to turn turn away and and and
adopt even new religious practices new
religious beliefs the way to do it
is not to write some long encyclopedic
entry or some long essay or some long
book about about why they should believe
what they should believe in some
rational argument now just change the
way they behave change the way they
worship you want people to worship a
different you want people to have
allegiance to a different kind of
country well change the pledge change
the flag change the symbols change the
behavior change the parades change the
marches
change the hand over your heart that
will do it a lot more than some rational
argument will okay speaking of prayer
it's Ash Wednesday at the beginning of
Lent we're all looking forward to Easter
we Christians out there
and uh so uh for woke Wednesday Mr
Davies has given me a uh a prayer
from a New York Times best-selling
Progressive Christian devotional can't
say the book is on my bookshelf but I
will get into it uh rest of the show
starts now you don't want to miss it go
to dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign